[Musique]
karim j'ai 40 ans je suis né à paris en
1978 et mon enfance n'a pas été celle
d'un gamin normal ma mère a fui les
violences de mon père biologique
deux mois avant ma naissance mon père
est d'origine algérienne est plus âgé
qu'elle est certainement qu'à ce moment
là de sa vie il n'était pas le meilleur
des conjoints et mon visage renvoyé à ma
mère toutes les souffrances qu'elle
avait vécu avec mon père et comme pour
se laver de toute trace de cet homme
dans sa vie elle a choisi de m'appeler
david alors durant les cinq premières
années de ma vie j'ai vécu seul avec ma
mère et puis un jour est arrivé celui
qui deviendra mon beau père j'étais
heureux je pensais retrouver un
équilibre familial une figure paternelle
et recevoir de l'amour mais je me suis
trompé car cet homme que je voyais comme
un père de l'âge de 5 ans jusqu'à l'âge
de 12 ans n'a fait connaître la
maltraitance la violence le racisme la
haine et la rage
bref un enfer j'ai bien tenté de fuir de
fuguer de m'évader de ce bourreau mais
la police et les services sociaux me
ramenait toujours à la case départ
c'est-à-dire chez mes parents
alors un jour je me suis dit mais bon
sang si jamais je me faisais attraper
certainement que je pourrai messti rhdp
de ce cauchemar
alors j'ai décidé d'aller voler en
faisant exprès de me faire attraper
afin que la police puisse me sauver et
m'éloigner enfin de mes parents et j'ai
12 ans quand les gendarmes m'amène à un
juge pour enfants et qui me dit tu es
trop petit pour aller en prison
mais tu n'es pas un trop grand pour
aller en foyer d'éducation spécialisée
et c'est là qu'il a décidé de me placer
jusqu'à ma majorité
la semaine suivante je me retrouvais
ghettoïser avec des jeunes un problème
comme
jusqu'à ma majorité et c'est une claque
donnée par un éducateur car je ne
répondais pas au prénom de karim qui m'a
révélé ma véritable identité
je ne m'appelait pas david mais karim et
plus précisément je m'appelais karim
david mohamed mokhtari a débuté une
quête identitaire et une errance
culturel qui m'ont conduit à la
délinquance et la délinquance à la
prison et j'ai 18 ans oui après un
braquage
lorsque la justice mme condamne à purger
une peine de dix ans de réclusion
criminelle alors la prison au fond de
moi je savais que j'irai je savais que
c'était inscrit profondément et de
manière fatale dans mon parcours alors
en regardant le drapeau français flotter
au dessus de la porte de la prison je me
suis dit que ici peut-être je pourrais
me réparer qu'ici certainement je
pourrais réparer ce que j'avais cassé
dans notre société et pourquoi pas même
ici à prendre le vivre ensemble et ce
qu'était la justice de notre pays
mais dès les premières secondes passées
entre ses murs j'ai eu cette sensation
terrible d'être avalés totalement par
une structure unitaire structure une
super structure de béton dans laquelle
je ne savais même plus où me situer
géographiquement les premiers mois sont
les plus difficiles à vivre car vivre
enfermé 22 heures sur 24 dans une
cellule de 9 mètres carrés avec trois ou
quatre personnes
ça n'est véritablement pas évident et
puis là-bas la violence le taux
d'addiction ou de personnes présentant
des troubles psychiatriques sont telles
que le vivre ensemble non plus n'est pas
évident
alors il m'a fallu trouver un sens à ma
peine pour m'en sortir mais on ne s'en
sort jamais seul alors j'ai commencé à
espérer du bien et la vie a commencé à
être généreuse avec moi j'ai fait des
rencontres extraordinaires qu'on
véritablement changé toute ma vie comme
ce jour dans cette promenade d'une
prison où je discutais avec l'un des
plus ancien détenu de france
un condamné à mort qui avaient été
graciés en 1982 et qui depuis purgé une
double perpétuité et il en était à sa
37e année de détention et il me dit tu
sais karim
la seule question désormais que tu dois
te poser ici c'est quelle est la
différence entre sept minutes dans
laquelle toi et moi nous parlons
maintenant est celle qui suivra alors
j'ai fini par me convaincre que la seule
différence qu'il pouvait y avoir c'est
ce que je ferai de sept minutes
alors avec cette question et surtout
avec sa réponse j'ai compris que je
pouvais encore agir sur le temps et
devenir maître de mon avenir
j'ai donc décidé de reprendre mes études
de mes explorer essayé de me rencontrer
essayez de voir tel était finalement les
ressources dont je dispose est à la fois
en mois mais aussi autour de moi pour
faire de cette peine un temps utile
autant pour moi que pour la société
un autre jour dans ma cellule toujours
j'ai eu la surprise de recevoir la
visite d'un aumônier catholique
manifestement il s'était trompé d'étagé
il souhaitait partir je lui ai dit non
on fait pas son marché dans ma cellule
alors je m'ai fait glisser le seul
tabouret que je possédais je veux
demander de s'asseoir
j'ai deviné un paquet de cigarettes dans
son pantalon et je vais demander de
manière assez agressive de me donner une
cigarette
il m'a dit monsieur vous avez l'air de
pas être bien
j'ai dit oui mon père si c'est comme ça
qu'on doit vous appelez bien sûr que je
ne vais pas bien et vous savez pourquoi
parce que je pense bien que même dieu ne
pourra pas me pardonner pour ce que j'ai
fait et tout en me tendant cette
cigarette il m'a dit une phrase qui a
changé est bouleversé mon existence il
m'a dit détrompez vous monsieur car dieu
éprouve ce qu'ils aiment et si vous avez
prouvé c'est qu'il sait quand vous vous
possédez les ressources nécessaires pour
surmonter cette épreuve
et c'est à cet instant que j'ai compris
que j'étais un prince habillée en
mendiant depuis 20 ans
il m'a appris à gérer ma colère à
prendre de la hauteur
il m'a approché de la philosophie du
spirituel
oui cet homme m'a montré le monde
autrement et surtout il m'a aidé à y
évoluer autrement
et puis enfin il ya cette femme qui est
entré dans ma vie une chance
extraordinaire pour un homme comme moi
qui pouvait enfin être aimé aussi elle
s'est posée comme un ange au travers de
mes parents pour me proposer à la fois
de l'amour est un avenir s'en est suivie
une correspondance de 4 ans qui s'est
concrétisée par un mariage qui dure
depuis 15 ans et deux magnifiques
enfants il caille mon épouse rania et
rabia nos deux filles à qui je fais
hommage aujourd'hui car elles ont su
faire de moi à la fois le mari le père
mais aussi l'homme que je suis
aujourd'hui et c'est ce regard que les
autres ont posé sur moi qui fait qu ma
réinsertion est effective aujourd'hui
car on ne s'en sort jamais seule on a
besoin d aide
il est normal de demander de l'aide et
ça n'est pas grave de recevoir du
soutien alors le sens de mon témoignage
aujourd'hui devant vous c'est de vous
poussez vous vous même un être et à agir
comme toutes ces personnes qui m'ont
tendu la main dans mon existence
parce que quoi au fond dans notre pays
la jeunesse va bien nous reste quelques
défis à mener comme pour ses cent
cinquante mille élèves qui sortent du
système scolaire chaque année sans
qualification aucune ou encore pour le
chômage des jeunes qui frôle les 20% et
parfois même plus dans certains
quartiers et pour ces centaines de
jeunes qui n'hésitent pas à mettre leur
vie et celle des autres en danger
au nom d'une idéologie mortifère or on a
tous dans notre parcours ou dans notre
vie une bonne étoile
un exemple quelqu'un qui nous aura
poussé à nous dépasse
pour moi ça a été
ce détenu cet aumônier et cette femme
mais pour vous c'est peut-être un ami un
proche un prof quelqu'un qui vous aura
poussé à vous dépasser avons fixé des
objectifs à atteindre un but alors parce
que j'ai envie de vous dire c'est
engager vous soyez inspirant participé à
préserver ce que nous avons de plus
précieux dans notre société en
préservant ceux qui sont les plus
précieux c'est à dire les jeunes c'est
notre responsabilité ne semble en tant
qu'adulte que d'accompagner ces êtres en
devenir
afin de leur permettre de mieux
comprendre la société et ses enjeux à la
fois oui pour aujourd'hui mais aussi
pour demain moi j'ai été déçu de mes
droits civiques
lors de ma condamnation et ce sont ces
jeunes qui m'ont montré comment en être
digne et responsable
ces jeunes louis professionnels de rien
mais motivés pour tous ces jeunes
engagés dans un service civique et qui
donnent de leur temps et de leur énergie
au service de populations qui vivent et
qui sont en proie à des difficultés à la
fois sociale et humaine
d'autres jeunes que je rencontre dans
des quartiers ailleurs et qui souhaite
aller en prison pour devenir des hommes
alors je me sers de mon parcours de mon
expérience de ma trajectoire comme un
point de preuves pour leur dire qu'il
est possible de vivre et être autrement
car je veux les convaincre par l'exemple
que le changement est possible à la fois
dans une trajectoire mais au fin fond
d'un individu
aujourd'hui je suis père de famille et
ma fille iranien récemment a eu à écrire
une dissertation qu'elle a intitulé mon
père cet espoir où elle dit il est
l'exemple est la preuve que même si on a
eu un parcours qui nous pousse à l'échec
il est toujours possible de se reprendre
pour réussir à se relever elle est ici
ce soir et dont ses yeux d'adolescentes
dans ce qu'elle a compris de moi et de
la vie oui je vois deux magnifiques
perspectives d'avenir alors j'ai vécu
des choses lui dans notre société c'est
vrai le pire et le meilleur en quelque
sorte dans tous les cas j'en suis le
témoin et mon devoir c'est de le
partager
pour que quel que soit le parcours des
jeunes il y voit une voix parce que je
crois que l'action d'un jour ne
détermine pas un homme pour toujours et
parce que je crois aussi qu à coups de
coeur et de regards bienveillants l'on
percevra des murs bien plus épais que
ceux de nos prisons ou de nos peurs car
c'est comme cela il me semble que nous
créons un espoir
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]